okay and it's an interactive love story
set in the multiverse whatever that
man's Islands you don't know what that
means
but we're doing I think I don't I
literally don't remember what it's
called it's like paradigm or something
parody key I don't know start without a
second
hopefully it says the title Oh
paranoia possibily yeah that's what it's
called okay no markers and Katie ain't
done so don't like her like you do where
are you going I'm going
you gotta go I'm going now now you're
going
what you say listen he knows Malka jets
out like that you don't know that pole
you don't know that I'm tired of it we
have a single thing in the universe we
haven't tried it understand what's about
five more minutes try to see there's
five minutes I'm going to change I think
that's the problem what is going on
[Music]
great that's wonderful I'll take it I'll
take it
see you're gonna go yeah
but you forget something cuz uh Terry
darling no no I can't go what up you
know exactly why I can't go I hate that
once again I can't read your mind
Juanito
please please just say goodbye so that
you don't I'm just going to go out and
win the rest of my days hearing hearing
you say fine like that okay so what do
you want to go and say goodbye it
goodbye Polly good luck
let's form the postcard take care
it's like the story doesn't change it's
just like the setting that they're in
changes we're going oh this one over
here looks good the far away ones here
okay now it's actually a little
different he just poured gasoline on her
I don't like how you can only go one at
a time the guy just quit no okay this
one they love each other
I don't like how you can see them over
there okay where's the woman should
break stuff okay I just couldn't take a
million pieces
don't worry about Ricki don't worry how
you wasted the past four [ __ ] years
of the bike the whole experience has
been utterly pointless
what do you last night you're gonna
Booker with me
he's Ricky I like that the music stays
though you know like the music
soundtrack isn't changing when I switch
between scenes
okay it's got dark on one scene
this is happy thank that our
relationship has made us stronger people
has made us grow as individuals yes you
do stain like filmed why just thinking
popping out no I don't want to go on it
I want to go all over here what's
happening here oh they're like merger
like I know you but every now and then
and I look at you and I feel like you
something completely new and it make me
just so weird
because our series I'm leaving we go
I guess I'm just glad that we have all
this [ __ ] or else you would have none of
it
that's a magic acknowledge she's got a
difficult one of it all oh stop anyway I
don't know what that means but I know
you
I know what you mean
are you getting a shirt that fit better
did that's your problem that's your main
problem right then you got to work on
that maybe either now or immediately
after now so what's a girl like you
doing where are you going I'm going
no you're gonna go I'm going now now
you're going right okay is it just going
it just got like this forever
okay well thank you for watching y'all I
hope you enjoyed this weird thing check
it out watch every single thing I don't
know what that says about five more
minutes in now yeah